when you got into metallica um
you're banned exodus they were pissed
right i mean
oh yeah they're so pissed you know
it was weird because i i formed exodus
in high school i thought that was my
band but then when i met these guys and
started playing with them i felt more at
home than i did
in the band that i started and i you
know there was a lot of
guilt that came along with that but but
the second i played with these guys
i just felt better how did you tell
those guys like how do you go to him and
say hey look metallica wants me to join
him so
uh i'm leaving you dudes it's it was
exactly that howard and they understood
who was it who did you talk to i talked
to gary holt the guitar player
paul bailoff the singer and tom hunting
the drummer
all at the same time they didn't kick
your ass uh we were all drunk
we were all drunk but then they didn't
kick your ass by the way
we hugged and then we we all started
wrestling which is what we usually
would do back then
i thought the legendary story was the
lead single walked over to you and
poured a beer over your head when you
told when you told him
that probably happened you don't
remember it but maybe that happened i
don't know we were all drunk
that happened so frequently i don't
think they were that was the beer that
was a normal
activity actually pouring beer on each
other wasn't the story was april fool's
day and you thought it was a joke that
that
metallica had called you yes it was on
april fool's
day and i thought it was a complete joke
i think i was sitting on the can
if you want a complete picture what's
that look like
you were sitting on the can i assume you
were uh making a dump
and uh you get this call you're playing
guitar while you're taking a dump that's
commitment
yeah and and you get a call that
metallica wants you it's
that's gotta be great
you